[Musique]
l'insertion et l'emploi a été au coeur
d'un séminaire organisé par la
préfecture et la caf de la réunion ce
mardi 12 octobre à la salle kerveguen de
saint pierre pour les acteurs concernés
dans le département pôle emploi les
missions locales principaux partenaires
de l'événement il était notamment
question de dresser un bilan de la
première année de mise en oeuvre de la
convention de recentralisation du rsa
vous parler de tournant parce qu'on a
mis en place une dynamique collective
cette dynamique collective a produit les
premiers résultats positifs mais nous
avons tout à fait conscience que le
chemin parcouru le reste il est encore
important est que
vraiment la mobilisation est toujours et
toujours et toujours d'actualité
c'est l'engagement qui a été pris ce
matin le bien
fait et bien ça produit des premiers
résultats mais nous devons plus que
jamais nous mobiliser pour aller encore
plus loin
intitulé fier de mon parcours le
séminaire était aussi destinée aux
bénéficiaires du rsa venus témoigner de
leur parcours
plusieurs tables rondes ont rythmé la
journée qui a vu la participation des
acteurs présents vous professionnels
bénévoles conseillers d'insertion
travailleurs sociaux ce qui reste à
améliorer
c'est notamment la coordination des
acteurs si on veut
offrir
à chacun à offrir ou redonner à chacun
une chance de rebondir dans la vie c'est
important que les acteurs soient
coordonnés pour rendre lisible et
accessible tous les dispositifs qui
existent il ya de nombreux dispositifs
ils sont encore méconnus et ils sont
méconnus parce que vu de l'extérieur vue
du public vue du bénéficiaire ça peut
être trop compliqué à comprendre à
accéder et donc la coordination des
acteurs c'est celle en jeu aujourd'hui
principal pour permettre le retour vers
vers l'insertion et vers l'emploi autre
temps fort l'intervention par
visioconférence de la ministre déléguée
à l'insertion brigitte klinkert qui a
évoqué la mise en place du nouveau s p e
services plus vite de l'insertion et de
l'emploi dans le cadre de la stratégie
nationale de prévention et de lutte
contre la pauvreté le sps est un
dispositif expérimental
nous sommes territoire d'expérimentation
le département marais au même titre que
quelques autres territoires et le s p e
seule occasion de faire en sorte que le
partenariat fonctionne mieux en mettant
en place des outils notamment des outils
numériques pour favoriser le suivi et
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
rsa donc c'est un renfoncement
du partenariat mais c'est aussi le
développement d'outils qui n'existent
pas jusqu'à maintenant d'outils pour
assurer un meilleur suivi de nos bébés
sur les quelque cent mille bénéficiaires
du rsa que compte la réunion trente
mille sont accompagnés par le
département 50000 par pôle emploi et les
20000 restants sont répartis entre les
divers organismes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]